[Musica]
ti devo confessare che
nel settembre del 2014 ha completamente
perso la testa
è successo a londra nel rapporto
nell'aeroporto di heathrow
ed è successo per colpa di un trolley
io sono stato per molto tempo quello che
viene definito un frequent flyer
ho passato una gran parte della mia vita
sugli aerei non li ho contati tutti ma
credo di aver salito con la scaletta
almeno un migliaio 1200 volte nella mia
vita ed ogni volta che viaggiavo con me
c'era il mio trolley perché il trolley
per un per un frequent flyer per un
viaggiatore assiduo non è un oggetto
qualsiasi è un vero e proprio compagno
di viaggio si sviluppi un rapporto di
amicizia
fa parte della della tua vita e cambiare
un trolley non è una scelta facile
perché il trolley ha una sua vita anche
quando non viaggia perché quando resta a
casa custodisce oggetti come il tuo
passaporto il secondo mazzo di chiavi
della macchina
il caricatore del telefono il caricatore
dell'ipad la camicia sottovuoto che
aveva portato via e pensavi di
utilizzare invece non ha utilizzato il
beauty che contiene tutti quegli oggetti
miniaturizzati perché tutto deve essere
miniaturizzato per cui lo spazzolino da
denti quello telescopico la schiuma da
barba quella piccolina sostanzialmente
la la tua vita si miniaturizza va un
pochino sotto vuoto perché in quel
trolley devi essere pronto poi in
pochissimo tempo a riempirlo a svuotarlo
per il prossimo per il prossimo viaggio
io non so quale sia stato il motivo per
il quale poi la mattina quando sono
partito da milano
ho deciso di cambiare trolley e di
utilizzarne uno nuovo
perché come dicevo cambiare trolley è
una scelta importante intanto perché lo
devi svuotare secondo perché chi come me
anche un po scaramantico lasciare un
trolley con cui è fatto centinaia e
centinaia di voli ti è sempre andata
bene non è proprio una cosa che fai
che fai volentieri però quella mattina
ha deciso di utilizzare un trolley nuovi
che avevo comprato qualche settimana
prima insieme un mio amico
parto per londra o due giorni di meeting
parto dall'aeroporto di linate tutto
funziona benissimo arrivo il venerdì
alle cinque di sera a londra devo
rientrare a milano faccio una di quelle
cose che ho fatto normalmente in una
giornata come tutte le altre e per
quelli di voi che sono stati a heathrow
probabilmente ricorderete che prima di
entrare al gate della sicurezza
c'è un box di metallo all'interno del
quale tu devi sposare posizionare il tuo
troll e perché questo verifica che le
dimensioni del tuo trolley siano
compatibili per portarlo in per portarlo
in cabina per portarlo a bordo
io arrivo sereno spedito come sempre
cerco di incastri mio trolley e per
qualche centimetro 3 4 cm il trolley non
entro nel box allora l'ha detto la
sicurezza
mi guarda con gentilezza con fare
british mi dice fuori per favore si
sposti dalla fila vada al check in e
imbarco il suo bagaglio e io ho detto
non se ne parla neanche che in bar col
bagaglio allora mi faccia provare di
nuovo
provo di nuovo provo a spingere tra il
manico insomma non c'è possibilità al
trono in un entro allora questo detto mi
guarda questa volta un pochino più
severe mi diceva sta procurando un certo
disagio agli altri passeggeri si faccia
da parte
vada al check in in barca il suo
bagaglio e io lì non so per quale motivo
perde completamente la testa
inizio a gridare come un pazzo a inveire
un po in italiano un po in inglese un
certo punto e credo che non sono finito
nei guai per le parole in italiano che
lui non ha compreso e tutti quelli che
mi vedevano da fuori hanno visto una
scena improbabile finché questo signore
con un certo piglio mi dice guardi se
non la smette sono obbligato a portarlo
nel portarla nel l'ufficio di polizia
del dell'aeroporto per cui per favore si
faccia da parte faccia passare gli altri
passeggeri
io me ne vado trafelato sudato rosso
paonazzo con probabilmente 200 su 140 di
pressione e decido però che non gliela
darò vinta per cui mi sposta di qualche
metro strappo fisicamente con le mani le
rotelle da
la base di questo trolley che era un
trolley nylon con la base di con la base
di cartone strappo le rotelle
mi spacco un'unghia mi sanguinano le
mani e la butta nel cestino e con un
pazzo mi dirigo verso di lui guardandolo
come in una sfida da film western piazza
il mio trolley dentro funziona entra lui
mi guarda mi fa passare e io arrivo
finalmente al gate uno straccio
praticamente perché un uomo che ha
passato una gran parte della sua vita ad
essere sempre molto sotto controllo
francamente ha ceduto non ho compreso
cosa mi fosse successo e mentre ero al
gate aspettando l'aereo rifletto su
questa situazione è stata davvero una
situazione particolare ho provato a
guardarmi da fuori
insomma ho cominciato a farmi qualche
domanda mi sono domandato ma per quale
motivo sono arrivato in questa
situazione di totale disequilibrio da
avere una reazione di questo tipo è la
risposta che mi sono dato è stata tempo
perché non volevo imbarcare il mio
bagaglio perché volevo guadagnare 20
minuti di tempo
all'arrivo linate perché di questo
stiamo parlando quando imbarchi un
bagaglio e la domanda quindi è stata ma
se il tempo è una di quelle parole che
continuo a ripetermi in continuazione
vengo quando avrò tempo a ho bisogno di
avere un po di tempo ci sarò con un
pochino più di tempo tempo era una
parola ricorrente che era così
importante da farmi perdere la testa e
allora ok che che importanza stavo dando
io nella mia vita al tempo e ho pensato
quindi che tempo era una parola
importante le parole sono importanti
perché le parole se le usiamo
correttamente possono avere un potere
straordinario
così ho deciso e ho riflettuto sul fatto
che in fondo io persona istintiva ed
emotiva ho sempre avuto le parole come
uno strumento razionale un contraltare
alle mie decisioni
nella mia vita di business e avevo
quattro parole chiare un acronimo si
citywire questo era un sistema di
decision making
io usavo per prendere decisioni
significava ogni cosa che fai
nel business devi essere sicuro di farla
prima di tutto nell'interesse
dell'azienda company secondo
nell'interesse dei clienti customer
dopo nell'interesse del team della tua
squadra e infine nel tuo personale
interesse e se questo può essere uno
strumento che nel business può essere
valido per sempre perché può piacere o
meno si può condividere o meno ma è una
struttura che ti permette di prendere
decisioni secondo un senso logico
ho detto allora perché non fare la
stessa cosa e applicarla la mia vita
privata io non avevo un acronimo per la
mia vita privata
e così ho detto lo andiamo a vedere
quali sono le parole che mi guidano oggi
che mi hanno portato in questo tipo di
vita e mi hanno portato a questo tipo di
reazione e ho fatto un esercizio
semplicissimo preso un foglio di carta e
ho cominciato a scriverle denaro
stabilità status and go
erano parole importanti per me il denaro
era importante lo status era importante
leggo era importante e la stabilità
anche non voleva una situazione con dei
rischi e poi lo cerchiate per dimensioni
cercando di capire quali di loro fosse
la più importante per costruire quello
che era il mio inconsapevole acronimo
che guidava le mie scelte di vita e non
a caso ho scoperto che era messa era un
casino e allora ho detto proviamo adesso
scrivere quelli che invece sono le
parole che vorrei inserire nella mia
vita quelle per cui vorrei prendere le
decisioni da oggi e le parole sono state
tempo il tempo importante perché il
tempo importante perché il tempo
significa perché volevo più tempo perché
volevo tornare a casa perché volevo
tempo da spendere per le mie cose e con
i miei affetti
io non credo a tutti quelli che dicono
che l'importanza del tempo non è la
quantità ma la qualità
questo per me è stato un alibi per tutta
la vita perché la quantità negli affetti
aumenta la qualità era lo scopo
[Applauso]
volevo avere uno scopo
volevo multidisciplinarità avevo passato
25 anni della mia vita
sempre nello stesso settore
dell'information technology
e poi volevo persone le persone erano
importanti volevo scegliere le persone
con cui lavorare poi volevo avere
divertimento perché il lavoro può essere
divertimento quando per la prima volta
ho cambiato lavoro nella mia vita e ho
detto a mio papà papà cambio lavoro
perché non mi diverto
lui mi ha detto sì ma stessa il pazzo se
vuoi divertirti va allo stadio
il lavoro è fatica perché nella nostra
concezione del lavoro era fatica e poi
volevo avere un in fa un impatto così ho
ricostruito la mia mappa cerchiando le
parole in funzione dell'importanza che
dovessero avere e ho costruito il mio
nuovo trony motiv che curiosamente in
inglese al gerundio diventa tippingpoint
il punto di svolta e poi li ho messi a
confronto
ho messo quali erano le parole che mi
guidavano e quelle che avrei voluto che
diventassero le parole con cui fare le
prossime scelte di vita e così ho fatto
una cosa che fino a qualche settimana
prima non avrei mai pensato di fare ho
dato le dimissioni
ho lasciato dopo 20 anni all'apice della
mia carriera l'azienda per la quale
avevo lavorato e ho lasciato soprattutto
tutte quelle cose che l'azienda mi aveva
dato status bigliettino da visita il mio
cognome è tornato ad essere il mio
cognome io non ero più bevilacqua di
sono tornato da essere david bevilacqua
quando mi presentavo con le altre
persone e ha cercato di riempire la mia
vita per rispondere a queste parole come
avete sentito o co fondato un'azienda
grazie un brillantissimo ragazzo
cesenate che questa la marcora mille di
cyber security svolgo attività di
advisor per diverse aziende e svolgo
attività in alcune aziende no profit
avrei potuto evitare che ci fosse stato
quel momento tilt l'aeroporto dietro ma
non l'ho fatto perché ho sottovalutato i
segnali che avevo ricevuto il nostro
corpo il primo a darci dei segnali io
negli ultimi due anni avevo avuto molti
più guai di salute di quelli che avevo
avuto nei precedenti
49 anni della mia vita niente di grave
grazie a dio ma tutta una serie di
problemi che non ho saputo leggere con
la giusta attenzione per cui il
messaggio che vorrei darvi ascoltate i
vostri segnali perché il nostro corpo ci
dà dei segnali e poi fate manutenzione
delle parole noi spesso utilizziamo le
parole senza sapere che senso che forza
possano avere mai venuto in mente un
libro che avevo letto di gianrico
carofiglio le parole servono a
comunicare e raccontare storie ma anche
a produrre trasformazioni e cambiare la
realtà quando se ne fa un uso sciatto
inconsapevole e se ne manipolano
deliberatamente i significati
l'effetto del logoramento la perdita di
senso bisogna sottoporre le parole a una
manutazione attenta ripristinare la loro
forza originaria e renderla di nuovo
aderenti alle cose
io ho sempre vissuto ha avuto bisogno
delle parole nel business per dare un
contraltare razionale alle mie possibili
decisioni emozionali e per questo per me
funziona perché non credo che la
risposta sia sempre mollo tutto e vado a
vivere sud america
ognuno deve fare i conti con le proprie
parole non ci sono parole fisse le
parole sono dinamiche e cambiano in
funzione dell'età delle circostanze dei
sentimenti e di quello che viviamo e
quindi io adesso guardando avanti ho
aggiunto una nuova parola lo scritto sul
mio libro come suggerisco voi di
prendere il vostro foglio e scrivere le
vostre parole è la parola che ho scelto
è scelta la scelta di poter continuare a
fare solo le cose che amo e con le
persone che stimo e questo spero che sia
una parola che troverete nel vostro
blocco che io spero inizierete a
scrivere stasera grazie
[Applauso]
grazie